doesn't matter it's just worse it
doesn't matter it's worse i would rather
[ __ ] punch me than slap the [ __ ] not me
no don't touch me
i agree if i had to choose i'd rather a
man punch me than slap me
because i've been slapped and i've been
punched and i'm gonna be honest with you
a slap reverberates through your face
yeah that [ __ ] leaves like a heat mark
yes it's not the same no it's not a
punch leaves you a little bit dazed a
punch like that leaves you vibrating a
punch i gotta punch you back yes a slap
i gotta kill you yeah
i gotta kill you we're going to no bro i
gotta kill you nah bro i got it it's
it's because it's it's not so much that
it's disrespect it's a it's a whole
other level of bro i was
my last year of high school [ __ ] slap
me for no like the dumbest reason
i sat in my room like kevin hart in
preschool like this piece called slapped
me
that's not bad she slammed me in for the
people too oh yeah oh i sat on that [ __ ]
you know what i caught her
shop the next day and i slapped the [ __ ]
out of her oh yeah oh yeah yeah oh yeah
i was not going to sleep another night
with that [ __ ] on my conscience i
slapped the [ __ ] out of her and she was
confused too i said touch me and get
watched what won't happen yeah cause the
thing that happened is that they don't
especially at that time they don't think
they've really felt untouchable no
untouchable
and i'm not gonna get you on that
because you when you slap me and you
moved on to the other day
it was over for you you moved on i
didn't
i geared that [ __ ] up
crank that [ __ ] back
when i moved wow you suffered my wrath
but i get it i get it
especially when you slap somebody bro
you can't slap somebody
and walk away you can't you you guys
gotta throw hands you gotta you gotta
throw hands you gotta do something
that's crazy everybody giving a shout
out to chris rock for being professional
i'm like nah [ __ ] i can't rock with
that but he would he but it's exactly
what the hell you said you said that
[ __ ] was shook because the
vibration you saw wow
it was i could imagine though like being
under those kind of lights you get me
it's not even so much the kind of lights
but but it is though the setting really
does affect it because you have to
imagine you ever been on stage yeah you
have all these eyes watching you and
you're different and you're alive
so it's not just the [ __ ] in
the room
this [ __ ] is you know you know whenever
you do live you are
you're conscious of the time right you
got a tom thing right you got to
make everything fit
there's publicity there's people now
this [ __ ] happened right
in front of ed everybody doesn't see it
right
it's staying online
you just
you just hit me live live